sir maybe we should sleep on it
why is his name bruno
calling what you want you just shut him
up okay say silence
silencio bruno and then you go to page
10 and you're kind of like trying to
come on louder
silencio bruno silencio bruno
silencio bruno silencio bruno
can you still hear him i can only hear
you
can you still hear him no just you
he jumps over you he smashes
into the sea and you it looks like he's
dead so this is like oh no
he's dead i killed him
did you see me on the bike julia said
look up
and then all of a sudden i was riding it
how about this
take me gravity because it'll be amazing
every day me and alberto are gonna ride
someplace new
and every night we'll sleep under the
fish
underdogs forever it's fine i'm not
human
it's fine i'm not human here hold this
here hold this looking for your tail
yeah it's called phantom tail you'll get
used to it
great i mean not great at all but fine
now walking is just like swimming like
it's the same thing but with
with no fins or tail and also there's no
water but
otherwise it's like the exact same thing
right walking
uh don't worry you're in luck i
basically invented it
oh it's just the greatest thing that
humans have ever made the vespa
oh just the greatest thing a human's
ever made the vespa
yeah i get one too sometimes alberto you
can't alberto you're gonna die
alberto don't put that in your mouth
luca it's simple
just don't listen to stupid bruno just
shut him up
by saying silencio bruno ah
rules are for cruel people
and ammo
that's bruno talking that's bruno
talking
go luca go
go luca go so
you boys aren't from around here huh are
you in town for the race
the puerto rosa cup right
that's why we got to win the town will
cheer our names
erkola's life will be ruined see any
fish
nice and then wait but then
where are all those
stars like the sun giant
raging balls of fire the stars are
circled by planets
look that's saturn it's my favorite
nice and this is the italian i'll give
you a read look that's saturn
it's my favorite el pibello
can you dodge obstacles what if an old
lady crosses your path
we have one week to train bronte
apostate
don't let them get in your head you can
do this
you can't swim you can barely ride a
bike
[Music]
i mean where are you from you're not
going to catch me
oh guys look underdogs forever
but mom we're always careful we
we look up you remember your uncle luco
and uh we go into
uh he has a bit of a heart attack and
you think it's complete oh this is
completely normal
oh he's okay just just punch his heart
uh-huh
well all right young man you're not
fooling anyone it's time
for us to go home
okay well
[Applause]
let that be a lesson to you honey uh hi
yeah honey no i
i don't honey i don't know if i support
i don't i would don't do this luca
luca yes maybe like
a little bit of uh there was some
apprehension still and you're like
luka
it's a human thing i'm kind of an expert
what does it mean
the thing you just said come on i'll
show you some more stuff
mother of pearl you live up here
yeah me and my dad he's not even here a
whole lot so i pretty much just do
whatever i want
isn't it dangerous yeah it's the best
everything good is above the surface
like what else air
gravity also known as falling
the sky clouds the sun
whoa don't look at it just kidding
definitely look at it
how you hurt my head
if there is so much as a scratch oh
someone got lucky today who got lucky
out of towners huh let me welcome you
so chicha i'm delighted to meet you
number one
and number two i love your stylish
clothes
what did you get them a dead body a dead
body i'm kidding ah look senor vespa
senor vespe that's great you're funny
hiya marco visconti five-time winner of
the porto rosso cup
how do you think i paid for my beautiful
vespa
hey stop looking she's too beautiful for
you hey
i brought some friends for dinner is
there enough before
[Music]
oh what's wrong with you stupid
why do you think he kills with those
anything that swims
today no that photo's a fake papa
everyone in porto rossa pretends to
believe in sea monsters
well i'm not pretending
how could my mother tell him about this
town of bloodthirsty lunatics
i still can't believe he would do this
it's not like him
just keep your guard up there's gonna be
land monsters everywhere
it's me you scared the scales off of me
geez you're strong i'm sorry i'm just a
little on edge no
i needed that it really woke me up wow
we look horrifying ugh gross
come on let's find our song